ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi stiamo
per fare la storia della gastronomia di
cucina buttata perché perché passato
abbiamo provato a fare la carbonara
francese abbiamo provato una pizza con
l'ananas e sotto abbiamo ricevuto anche
dei commenti per ciò che dicevano sì
vabbè ma non si possono caricare troppo
queste persone perché giustamente non
essendo italiane non è che sappiano
benissimo cosa stanno facendo ecco
perché mi sono detto va bene perché non
proviamo a fare un qualcosa che fanno
all'estero
in realtà non è vero che lo fanno
all'estero perché non provare a fare un
qualcosa che fanno solo in italia in
realtà tanto tempo che volevo provare a
prendere un panino di una catena di un
fast food e tentare di rifarlo in casa è
uno dei miei preferiti è il crispi beppe
con il problema è che la salsa di bacon
è stata per anni una specie di segreto
di fatima in cui ingredienti erano tipo
la ricetta è la coca cola nascosti al
mondo intero ma di recente non so quanto
recente sono usciti gli ingredienti e ho
visto su internet e il video di un
collega allo chef roberto valbuzzi che
proprio nel profilo ufficiale di
mcdonald quindi stiamo parlando di cioè
non so come dire approved by mcdonald's
quindi non si può scherzare adesso se
questa salsa non viene come deve venire
perché io veramente sono qui per giocare
seriamente
ho visto il suo video e quindi ho deciso
di fare questa salsa e provare ad
assemblarla nel panino a parte che c'è
un botto di roba dentro questa sull
sfondo christine bacon che lo credo che
era impossibile da rifare perché per
farlo avremo bisogno di tre uova olio di
semi di arachide attrito senape
concentrato di pomodoro zito collini e
te l'aspettavi agli in polvere capperi e
questa cosa che non penso che se stesse
in cucina che è l'estratto di carne che
per assurdo si trovava un e nei
supermercati credono nascosta da qualche
parte
separiamo i tuorli con il grembiule
lancio melo non c'è perché viola
iniziamo quindi tre cuochi 50 g di
senape come faccio a pesare la serata ha
un'idea ho capito l'idea geniale è detto
che è molto cena posa vero perché ne
abbiamo meditato all'interno dei seri
mcdonald cerico che tossisce girando su
se stesso abbiamo un laboratorio negli
esperti quindi metteremo meno senape
meno capperi al limite vi aggiungiamo
anche il tuo parlare non mi sembra
saggio appunto che dovesse una cosa è
già troppo secondo me 13 grammi intanto
si fa sotto in tempo a raggiungere a
togliere 30 grammi di concentrato di
prodotti più di pomodoro i capi sono
tanto forti da questo però tipi
cerealicoli le palline 18 watt e da cui
sembrano calcolo 7 g io ci metto invece
che 23 cetriolini i centri secondo me ci
stanno o meno incisivi di quel
m'aspettavo sto cambiando un po le dosi
mi sento è stata chiamatemi ronaldo non
è il calciatore aglio in polvere a buffo
vedere come ci stanno i primi i denti
sacco e 10 grammi di agro di spirito tra
parentesi aceto è come se dicessi in
quanto mi piace il tuo conserva caccole
si dice nel senso perché ci metto
pochissimo ragazzi sembrava sembrava
meno
sembra gianmarco sale affumicato e
attraverserà affumicato sarei confuso
beh sono molto simili sale la cipolla
dove noi metteremo del sale normale
voglio dire un po di sana affumicato la
cambia cavo è vero c'è il cappero 150
millilitri di speranza utilizzerò una
tecnica speciale cioè prima frullo tutto
vedo che tassello sta dunque 150
millilitri ok prima 20 150 millilitri in
un contenitore e poi mentre purtroppo
tardi
io sto aggiungendo un po di sé nate a
150 sono tanti sì no no mi sono le
strade carne che dite del segmento
adesso un casino
a rigare che è successo l'estratto di
carne potrebbe cambiare il risultato
ancora in meglio
curioso perché io l'ho già san giova
questa rozza proprio assaggiare
dell'ottimo è più buona la tua ci si
avvicina a doversi mettere più set up e
pure sono e più scena perché il sale
affumicato stava bene tutto questo poi
affumicato grazie il sale ad alzare
rotti dei sapori ci si avvicina un sacco
forse col salatini kato sarebbe stato
ancora più simile partiamo con
l'assemblamento cuciniamo e facciamo
domani si può come non detto
a questo punto iniziamo a cucinare gli
ingredienti principali del crispi noi
abbiamo trovato un bacon particolarmente
spesso quello che dovremmo fare adesso è
trovare un metodo quindi per appiattire
credo di avere in mente un'idea piazzate
poi una pellicola sopra le fette in modo
da coprirle perfettamente ok così è
molto più sottili di prima sempre stesso
procedimento di primavera coprite la
cosa positiva anche che muovendovi in
cucina facendo questa cosa iniziato a
bruciare anche le calorie che assume
rete a breve sono molto più sottili si
sono molto più sottili e pierre fra la
bistecchiera elia puliamo bene se
abbiamo la fortuna di per una
bistecchiera quindi utilizzeremo quella
altrimenti usate una ferita normale e
intanto prendo i panini e li divide a
metà prestito fwc calerà nel campo al
volo ma è così fosse mi vendi lobby non
si scherzi a parte della ricetta
ragazzina k
questi devono diventare incartapecoriti
si era trovato al supermercato al posto
di queste prendete quella delle
confezioni proprio sottile sottile
sottile noi non abbiamo trovato che ha
montato per comunque pancetta di qualità
sempre nelle nostre cucine insieme
hamburger di carne chianina sempre le
nostre cucine ammazza chef mario di
ancora più sottile
no non sono brutte ha fatto guardalo 15
scusano dell'ing iniziamo nel frattempo
a studiare come dovrà essere assemblato
quindi o che una foto del crispin pane
bacon hamburger formaggio hamburger
salsa pane che non ho mai visto chef ma
riesce frigo così felici di questa
cucina
cominciamo quindi a creare il primo
strato come se fossero il panigaccio
ovvero bisogno di mettere il becco bruce
carlo vai con dio
no no no in questo modo ne abbiamo quasi
tutti però non entra non è vero arrivo
non entrano no no sono integri non
entrano è ricorso intanto questo è di
non sono d'accordo che le piegano detto
sorella ma guardare invece panini al
latte li trovi proprio a mcdonald devi
salvare la padella
doveva dirci che tutto verrà varato in
formato ma il padre l'ha detto allora
abbiamo fatto io
io gli ho già in bocca
ricordati di chiudere la bocca ma gli
metto doppia sottiletta perché sono
molto piccole queste incredibili a una
enrico io ti odio salpare costo del pane
buzzi chance non chiudere toglie
[Musica]
no
a me piace molto questa divisione
cappato
essere quattro fratelli vuol dire che
automaticamente se non fai tutto quale
ti ammazzi dalla figura
chi è qua è perfetta la carne anche
mista e colla alla paletta citate
belli di quelli del mezzo io metto
questi da parte un secondo e finisco di
assemblare questo qua
metti l'hamburger sopra a bondi con la
salsa ragazzi io cioè mettere così
ventilati fanno che mi ero dimenticato
il suo bellissimo molto bello ok no
è delizioso ha lasciato andare intanto
gli altri di hamburger e velocissimo e
sembriamo anche gli altri
[Musica]
questo era il crispi back bacon fatto in
casa
un tripudio di roba di reato il momento
per la vostra città la vostra cin cin
cin cin
ma senza ci sta tutta pochissimo
delizioso ragazzi fate la mamma mia
ragazzi italiani su instagram se lo fate
ci prendiamo una pausa lunga una
settimana per mangiare e digerire questa
cosa qui continuate a scrivervi partite
notifiche sono le parti nessun video si
chiama persone domenica
ciao sul suo successo
[Musica]